une grande planète et c'est super d'être de retour
ravi de vous rencontrer aujourd'hui celui qui
me vient vraiment à l'esprit est le premier moment
où je suis arrivé à la station spatiale
après avoir appris l'existence de la station spatiale
pendant tant d'années l'avoir vous savez
à ce sujet est  cet endroit incroyable où
nous faisons de la science géniale au profit de
la terre, un laboratoire unique en son genre et
de voir que c'était vraiment réel
de rencontrer ma nouvelle maison pour l'année prochaine
était un sentiment incroyable que c'était comme
quelque chose  qui avait été discuté et
formé pendant tant d'années
a pris vie et non seulement cela,
mais je dois voler dans cet endroit
et ce sera juste quelque chose que je n'oublierai jamais
et II Sirota garderait le vôtre ce
petit toi  je sais découvrir des muscles que je
n'ai pas ressentis depuis un moment et des choses comme
ça n'ont pas vraiment eu mal aux pieds
mais je l'ai remarquée environ un jour où
j'avais mal au cou et je me sentais comme un enfant de
deux semaines que je vous  je sais que je
travaillais dur pour tenir ma
tête b  ut sachez que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
que la transition de retour ait été assez facile
et j'ai d'excellentes équipes qui s'assurent
que cela se produise et le genre
de cheerleading mental que vous vous faites
à vous-même que j'ai utilisé, je dis toujours comme mettre
quelque chose à répéter  dans ta tête ça
va être constructif donc ne réfléchis jamais